the fda and cdc are pausing
one of the covit vaccines the johnson
johnson vaccine here
is their here is their statement
quote we are recommending a pause
in the use of this vaccine out of an
abundance of caution
as of april 12th 6.8 million
doses of the vaccine have been
administered in the us cdc
uh in the u.s rather than cdc and fda
reviewing data involving six reported
u.s cases of a rare but severe type of
blood clot
in individuals after receiving the
vaccine right now these adverse
events appear to be extremely rare okay
so they're pausing it now
i hate to say i told you so but i told
you so there are two big arguments here
and they don't cut neatly across party
lines there are some republicans
who are super into the vaccine some who
even seem to
support some kind of vaccine passport
and there are
some left wingers who maybe are a little
bit more skeptical of the vaccine so i
think here that broadly the two camps
you have people on one side saying come
on it's only six cases
the risk of blood clot from birth
control drugs from oral contraception is
much higher
no reason to pause it let's keep pumping
out that vaccine
then you have people on the other side
saying see we told you so the vaccine
isn't safe it was rushed through
nobody should take the vaccine and here
i am
right in the middle holding the same
position i've held from the beginning
which i think is being proven truer and
truer each day which is that
anything you do in politics and in your
personal life is is going to involve
some degree of risk
and a great key to politics which none
of the rationalists on either side on
the left or on the right want to
acknowledge
is prudence prudence is not just a
virtue broadly
it is specifically and especially a
conservative virtue
you weigh your risk if i were
extremely obese and 85 years old
i would very likely take that vaccine
because i would feel that i had some
risk
some serious risk of coronavirus if i am
a relatively healthy 30 year old then
i probably won't take the vaccine
because i don't think i'm at great risk
and by the way if god forbid if i get
the virus
if god forbid i have some terrible
adverse side effect
do not let them write articles about me
let's say virus skeptic
or vaccine skeptic has a terrible
adverse side effect or
adverse consequence of the virus don't
let them write those articles
because i am acknowledging i know that
there is a risk but there's a risk in
anything in life
and i'm just making a risk calculation
based on the numbers here
based on the data the science and i'm
recognizing that i have a greater risk
of getting in a car
and drive driving to work than i do from
the coronavirus as a relatively healthy
millennial doesn't mean i have zero risk
i'm just recognizing that all of life
has a risk
so it seems to me people ought to use
their prudence and their judgment
now president trump interestingly came
out and is very upset at the pause in
the vaccine he says
the biden administration did a terrible
disservice to people throughout the
world by allowing the fda and cdc to
call a pause in the use of the johnson
johnson vaccine
dr fauci on the other hand is saying
i don't think it was pulling the trigger
too quickly to pause the vaccine
we are ruled by the science and not any
other consideration
first of all we are not ruled in this
country by the science at least we're
not supposed to be we are supposed to be
ruled by ourselves
within the confines of the constitution
using our higher reason
when the science capital s with a
trademark over the e
and its high priest its pontiff dr fauci
are not supposed to rule us
and the science seems to change day by
day by day
the science would not have been a great
guidepost in assessing your
risk from the virus or from the vaccine
the science told us don't wear masks
through the pontiff dr fauci then a few
weeks later the science told us you have
to wear masks
through the pontiff dr fauci then the
science told us there's no risk
whatsoever
from the vaccine then the science told
us there is such a risk that they're
going to pause the vaccine
and maybe they've said it's going to be
a short pause but then other people have
said it might be caused indefinitely
so the science quote unquote is not
going to guide you your prudence and
your higher
faculties of reason will hey smash
that like button subscribe hit the bell
so that you do not miss
any content from the michael knowles
[Music]
show
[Music]
you